this is a production of Cornell
University
well thanks a lot it's good to be here
so I'm going to talk today again as it
turns out on an ongoing projects with
broccoli that's been moving bathroom
floor over the years in its recently
started moving faster again and the
issue is to have a broccoli industry in
the history states rock resort vegetable
that is consumed to an astounding
expense it has this reputation people
like but it turns out that people are
eating it perhaps in secret that people
are on the eastern seaboard on the order
of hundred million pounds a year in turn
and the broccoli that we're eating is
grown almost exclusively in California
and Arizona Mexico we really don't grow
any of it and it's a new york's a great
place to raise cabbage whole crop roll
like the dickens here but rockets not
part of part of the picture
so I'm going to talk today first of all
to tell a little bit about what's the
problem a little bit of some of the
genetics that we've done over the years
if you try to figure out what's
controlling the development in broccoli
and some of the gene regulation be
fairly quick on these to cloak did this
work and reporting on it just a few
years ago and then talk about what it's
going to take to develop a broccoli
industry here in the next few years so
the problem is that you get totally bra
so if you're sitting in the back row you
may be saying huh okay to me if you pay
attention see but the growing conditions
that we have on an East Coast result all
too often in broccoli that has yielded
fine but nobody wants to buy it and so
it cost you an awful lot expensive
enough to grow that even a small field
would be an investment of thirty forty
fifty thousand dollars it's all been
trained if it works like this
so we know cauliflower broccoli we think
those are two perhaps even different
species turns out that nothing of the
sort it's that you have a rest of
developments at different stages and it
keeps growing bigger and bigger but
staying at the same stage of development
a little bit unusual effects are the
extreme cases and so you can have where
you get a reproductive meristem form and
it just makes more reproductive
meristems and that's our familiar
cauliflower they can do that for a while
and then start to make the first bit of
a floral priori which is happy to do
that one there there's a little starting
to become a little fear the stem can
elongate a little bit this is actually a
commercial variety which for no good
reason is called purple cauliflower it's
not cauliflower insistently purple
either so that's a form that exists
commercially its intermediate then we
have broccoli that can make bugs that
are too small in here when it's stressed
but there's other buds that are
developing well regular broccoli and
then this happens to the guideline but
there are many brassicas that would make
really big flower buds they come much
closer to opening so these are all
stages of arrests they spend some time
and that sort of uniformly all in their
stems or
organs develop the same state so that is
a continuum that exists genetically we
just happen to like a couple of
different spots and so we end up eating
a little bit here and there no good so
if what you can see is that there are
these worlds and the flowers developing
fluorescence is tacked together tight
and it normally broccoli bucks look like
these guys here and those are ones that
in this case got plastic critical
sensitive stage of development before
they experienced a temperature that was
high in these little guys were delayed
because they were not getting the
appropriate signal to keep going
developing further and so they've ended
up a few days apart in their development
and one of the other things that happens
because these little guys are growing
slower the plant is growing fast and go
somewhere you get actually a little bit
of release of vegetative meristems leaf
primordia Brecht's overdevelop
and so you get something that's called P
she heads if you look at the common
getting breast bit problems so we've got
cauliflower in four different types of
broccoli and a couple of different types
and have them at these different
temperatures you get different kinds of
developments so here we have the regular
Rockaways is cold it gets beautiful
broccoli as it warms up you start
getting these little in floral primordia
delay development in if it gets too hot
he just repeated on the other hand with
cauliflower cap winter cauliflower
that's cold to get nice call so it's
just the reproductive meristem late
cauliflower is it's somewhat higher
temperatures early cauliflower tropical
called flowers actually our summer
temperatures will produce all of these
if they did teapot pages for me
vegetative the signal to grow
reproductive isn't there it's not
getting chilling hours if that's a
familiar concept to you and a lot of
these call flowers if it gets too cold
develop the little floral crime or dia
they're often white called r IC it gets
too warm there's a the really late ones
will start to develop brags they look
fuzzy
it's not advertising so the sensitive
stage during development this is the
vegetative meristem triggered to go
reproductive so all of the work on
fertilization and induction of flowering
all that sort of stuff that happens in
between those two the part we're going
to talk about is what happens next if
you're working with a spring ephemeral
like a rag doll for instance many other
plants go through these phases very very
quickly once they're committed to
flowering a flower there are complex
ones actually the one that's most
similar to this is lilac closely related
to it all but very similar in its
inflorescence development so you have in
the axial here there's a little flex
bucket that's the sign that it's gonna
be productive then you start getting
meristems made on
they go out ramify to get more and more
these guys so this is almost a
millimeter across or starting to see
some of the racks there and here there's
a few floral priority of starting to
form you can see sequels right on the
edge when they make floral primordial so
if it continues like that it will make
cauliflower and if when it's really
small it's triggered to make floral
priority of this will become broccoli so
that's the difference between
cauliflower broccoli right that one
that's 10 pounds so we have the pathways
that drive flowering so the vegetated to
reproductive transition there's a gene
called we feed it is often responsible
for this when it gets turned on it goes
reproductive and there's a bunch of
pathways so economist means that when
it's old and off your gifts up and said
it's welcome in a flower here want a
photo period so that it happens at the
right time of year vernalization so it
happens at the right time of year
there's a gibberellin pathway all of
them feed in to the same gene this gene
turns on a gene called a pet Allah or
one of a number of genes in that family
that triggers flower formation is an
organ and so that's the late step that I
showed and so that seems to take
chilling hours where the induction of
flowering usually
joining me in the range of five degrees
10 degrees in the broccolis it seems to
be that the chilling required here the
threshold temperature below which
gelling hours are counted is somewhere
in the 20 Celsius so fairly warm and
incidentally where our summer night so
the problem is that it's not
accumulating chilling hours in the
summer nights getting enough cool
conditions to go on no just to show you
what this is more cut it a while going
on so this isn't a vegetative stage the
background is purple silver white silver
brains are where the gene is expressed
with the least the vegetative States
that's very little of it but then when
you start getting the reproductive
meristems Foreman there's a lot of
expression at the tip of those so
there's this is a reproductive meristem
is making expression is and then you
start getting flowers and in terms of
what little expression they're down here
where it's making
more meristems nearly floralprint
whereas 81 this is the early floral
meristem use the April dome that's going
to be a sequel sequel so lots of
expression in their developing flower
you see expression
so that seemed like the key genes right
that that's the turning them on at the
right times what's going to make flowers
develop properly and since that's the
difference between broccoli cauliflower
there's been some study of that and so a
number of people working a number of
people working on those the rapid
offices and brassica oleracea have
identified that 81 and alcohol flowers
very similar taking one just happens
only occur in fresco ratio the mutations
in these are the cause of the difference
and so it could be that the more
sensitive ones just have fewer copies
and so it takes more signal to get them
going to take them over the threshold or
something so that looks good in some
crosses between cauliflower and broccoli
it made as a segregated mapping
population and it behaved very nice just
as you would predict so we took that
model and we looked at what the
collection in the germ plasm for pasta
Tori was so this is work with join the
baits and their Robertson Angela
although at the gym class repository so
we tested a number of different models
to see whether they would predict the
phenotype that we actually saw it so one
is that this cauliflower gene is
responsible for the difference that was
the original proposal and a second one
that it's a kettle of change or that
your dominant bio consists of locusts
it's an additive by each locus
you're on or off or it's just edited
will sell me dumb the wheel street hat
and so the one that the ones that come
out significant one that's particularly
significant is the dominant by baggage
so that's good but then you look at how
much of the variation in phenotype is
explained by it seven percent so even
though we got the certificated show some
things happen percent isn't much so the
genes probably do what they're supposed
to do but they're not really explaining
the variation that we're seeing that
population so there's clearly a lot
morning so we wanted to dig into that so
this is where Denise did a lot of her
work music a genotype called green
harmony this is a commercial cauliflower
that's grown in Taiwan which is one so
they did 32 day 25 ninth and an ice
cream per head of cauliflower in the
field this was growth chamber room so
it's nice about this is we could either
have it remain as the reproductive
meristems we can make floral primordial
intermediate temperatures or make a
regular front when we've drawn this in
the field the ones that finish up and
i'll just look like this
same plenty as it goes on change its
appearance so by using these we could
look at the expression of these and some
related genes to see whether they could
we could attribute to them or to the
steps before that we should really say
so with with leaky whether it's doing
something or not if it's turning on it
means some one of these is starting so
we're really looking at them as
detectors of all the stuff that's
happening in pathways complicated enough
specific
and so the way we looked at it so these
are in Catalan cauliflower into is a
achievement a similar role Ricci is the
one that starts off flowering and
terminal flowers the one that maintains
the meristem actually should be getting
out of here as the flowers are formed
and so this this axis is going to be how
many folds of two does the expression
change for x expression log scale
and so this is done with real-time pcr
normalized that sort of thing and what
we see is that in going from the floral
primordium to the whole floral bud these
flower genes really aren't changing so
the expression that happens in the
primordial is the same as what's going
on flower buds so they're not driving
enlargement of the weepies going down
that's normally what happens with it in
terminal flowers going down a bit that's
normally with cabins as the flowers
develop so don't we don't have any real
good candidate for something that has to
suddenly turn on for these floral
primordia to move ahead become the
flower on the other hand looking for the
release from the reproductive meristem
either in peril of one or something else
which turned on by the same pathway that
turns on them
arrest at the face they're breaking that
arrest are turning those new jeans on so
we have at least candidates for breaking
of that stage there's an interesting
team called fruitful and it is spelled
with two L's Wow and these are really
potentiate errs of the floral jeans it's
all your doings but these would be a
good candidate for being me or something
else that would turn on to really make
those jeans more effective and what
would you see a change in expression of
both of the transitions they're both
heading down and so that doesn't fit the
model a turning on the bridge you can
run and also there they're relatively
similar at both transition so it doesn't
seem like they're specific one
transition so that when alas isn't
providing
and then there was a mother jeans fit
were curious about
unusual floral organs that was it turned
out expressed at very low levels and
their real change in that one here's one
that cauliflower curved expression but
that's really all that's known about it
doesn't have a fun what we were testing
was whether it was actually holding the
cauliflower Kurt that it was preventing
the release of that to make the floral I
maurya but absolutely no change there
and then it disappears once the flower
buds are sort of data
play a role in at a different stage
so yeah om was another regulatory gene
that were expected to come up as the
flowering develops but really only the
in the whole group only 280 months are
really responding the whole suite of
jeans that's usually associated but that
are really not moving up some of them
are going down so the story
the story of turning on me feat which
then turns on ap my expression we're not
we're not getting the signature of that
happening and it's difficult to go too
far down this road because the
regulatory mechanism keeps getting so we
haven't even considered in trouble the
small RNA expression bridges are known
to the flight roll and similar
mechanisms so for the time being we left
that one there so I want to move on to
some reading so back at the ranch more
or less literally we've been doing work
on how to do better selection so by
dividing the responses down that are the
phenotype that you see in
high-temperature the stuff the ugly
heads their leafy they're uneven in
different ways dividing that up into
individual physiological responses that
starts making it possible to do
selection that is Garrett rule before
they done selection except the
good-looking ones and those were just
escapes as we plant them the next turn
in the whole lotta and local and keep
the good ones plant those in the local
agent so it been very very difficult to
get heritable selection so by selecting
for much more specific things than looks
ugly it was possible start to make
headway and expose them to high
temperature
today to get roughly the right
temperature that they were supposed to
and so remove it so there is to remind
you sure you some not so bad looking but
not good enough to sell so this one has
a few oversized but how the colors
minute or not that the center of the
worlds are flying me so it looks
polka-dotted in the field so that's what
we need to improve on and so this is
kind of getting too weird what's the
opportunity for producing broccoli in
the east so if you look at cabbage is a
sample easy throws anywhere whole crop
you see that new york has a lot of
production 14,000 acres is a big chunk
in California up and down these Coast
Florida and Texas sir
production so clearly the East Coast is
well suited for growing both crops when
you look at where broccoli is grown it's
virtually a little bit in the Arizona
desert for winter production and then
intercostal County angels one farm with
4,000 acres but otherwise it's pretty
sparse on so how are we going to you
well put together a plan so the USDA
started this thing called the specialty
crops research initiative a couple of
years ago and the instructions were take
a big problem to find the whole solution
we had what seemed like an awfully big
problem to us and basically to readers
in need the whole solution turns out to
be fairly complicated because we set our
goal is a year around supply while the
volume that the market and the market
demands a lot and we got this goal
basically from the planning process that
this is what the retailer's want the
supermarket's were totally consistent in
saying if it's not a year-round so five
no box little okay that makes it a lot
harder but on the other hand we know so
why do we wanna do is that well the
first thing is the technology
breakthrough which is that three
breeding programs that started to
develop through
and let's chill Christmas Geneva and
Mark fun at the usda-ars in Charleston
South Carolina and Jim Meyers Oregon
State's gym sex with in reading broccoli
for the East Coast for organic
production number here is that with the
organic seed initiatives in court
so this is one of grips breeding lines
growing the same conditions as the other
picture specially so that's nicely
uniform that's what we need for some
there's another one of them so that's
that's what they're supposed to look
like I'll show you a couple there good
rockin pictures so why should we do this
now besides that we're ready to do
something to sell it to the other folk
why is this the right time so there's a
number of economic factors why this
should happen now first of all the
transportation cops have gotten very
funny these whole fuel when we
originally put this together was running
around five dollars a gallon it looks
like it's back up there now so it costs
to transportation from California maybe
even the California surfers start
looking around camping procent this
closer to our markets water availability
in the West is starting to get more than
and rock through life's a lot of farm
farm fertilizer also the food safety
rules are changing
attention last November December when
the Senate was busy with the new food
safety legislation the kinds of things
you have to do in the field prevent
bacterial infection human pathogen
infection of fresh produce especially
something like broccoli candy bra that
you need to really change a lot of the
practices and cold has a lot to do with
it and not storing your question alarms
on there's an opportunity in consumption
is still going up so even if the
California drawers continue to grow just
as much consumption these is going to go
up so we'll still need to be consumption
of cabbage
New York growers perspective there's a
lot more promise in profit i also have
social factors that come into play local
foods are four star great interest so
what exactly constitutes local find
broccoli new supermarket I don't know
the answer to that was pretty sure that
in the same nearby states that are
across the country or consumers are
interested and sustainability of food
production is getting a lot of attention
so there's a life cycle assessment is
actually a field in economics where
they're trying to figure out how to
figure out what the carbon footprint of
something is when you figure it for its
entire life cycle it's not a simple
manner it severely yield
and a year and a half ago Walmart
started up with the sustainability index
that they are really pushing down to all
of their suppliers so when I saw them
they were really excited because they've
been able to cut about one order off the
flat of the cardboard box Atlanta and
that same thousands of Thomas's healed
so something like that matters to them
imagine what not having to truck for
lunch or broccoli and ice across the
country they're also trying to source
most of their produce on the east coast
from the i-95 corridor so that's a big
factor and the fact that the specialty
crops research initiative is there and
so to overcome the barriers to getting
there we need the germ plasm that works
we need seed companies to produce seed
of that farmers provides we need farmers
start raising the crop knowing that they
have good varieties knowing that they
have customers and then you need the
coordination so that there is supply
coming from the east coast somewhere on
these post from during the entire year
so middle of summer is really tough
there's a few places that are pulling it
off now high elevation and and
concentrated on the ground report that's
middle of winter in Florida
so we've got the project there's a big
breeding components and the breeding
component is both public and private the
idea is to develop new varieties that
perform consistently well here we have
yet to find commercial varieties that
would be consistent year after year to
did that we're doing regional testing so
we have five testing sites where we're
going to do exhaustive trials on these
things multiple planting dates lots of
replication analysis or not only what
they look like by nutrition qualities an
extension component is
in at least five areas the idea is to
develop groups of producers that
together can supply the market
particular fairly large falling
production and do that then you have the
infrastructure so that they can have
cooling and transportation got a few
hours field to where the broccoli is
essentially acts or up sells you need
the marketing system the distributors
will biophys it takes a lot of
relationship building to make that work
so we've got a group in Maine we've got
a group during New York got a group in
Virginia lower elevation got high
elevation in North Carolina and we've
got it South Carolina Georgia for for
the November to
and who's involved with this so we've
got the the three academic readers that
I mentioned before but then we brought
in four different seed companies and the
part of this project is that you have to
have match from industry so these four
companies that among them actually
committed quite a large sum of money
that they're going to spend on their
efforts to read specifically for so
that's an unusual thing for them to do
is we do them also
but they've committed to test and
release varieties here over the
five-year course of the project spent
the morning at OSP trying to figure out
what the rules are going to be for
trading the seeds back and forth and
when you have to tell them what you can
write on packets like that so this is
mark Farnham from the Charleston dress
dear reprogram Powell Smith is the
extension agents for Clemson so he's
working with a group of growers Clayton
for all the growers in the South
Carolina area down by their deep this is
almost pure Santa completely different
from growing in New York so they're
developing the extension program for the
farms in South Carolina is going to be
really different from developing the
extension program here it's not just the
time of year their fertility populations
that sort of thing are now they are all
going to be what r ZAR we're going to
have to push yields very high the same
way they do with cabbage to make it work
here being within twenty percent of your
maximum yield isn't quite good enough
really got to push it all the way to the
top so current recommendations are kind
of in the ballpark but we're not
interested
I've involve are interested in very dust
so that's going to take so the extension
team the time the leader for the
extension component christy walton with
our vegetable program is organizing the
western New York growers mark haddon
warmer breeder but it's now at extension
in Maine so he's working a little bit
with the very successful farm in Maine
but it's also working to develop our
group in southern Maine both to the
boston market with Morris is an
extension agent with Virginia Tech
outside of Roanoke who's put together
this fantastic group of growers
supplying a supermarket chain down there
it's smaller growers but their marketing
together it's exactly the model that
we're going for it so that's a model
that we're trying to spread so that it's
not just for the really big rotors we've
got the really big growers in on the
front end but having this be scaled and
drill is important you can keep
janeane davis is with north north
carolina at what some of you know it's
there Fletcher station fault in elk
river but they have two farms there one
research farm but it's where all of
those mountain lion tomatoes came from
so they need to rotate something free
candidate and I'm in this bought a farm
that is their organic do so they're
going to be reading for organic growers
that there's quite a few embellishment
that I showed you earlier is with
Clemson and he's working with the larger
growers in South Carolina Georgia
Florida this is one of the big growers
also down in South Carolina you can see
they're kicking operation so this is a
conveyor belt that goes to the tractor
the trim put it in the one-pound boxes
and they're just on this self unloading
trailer that you're going behind so they
cover
that's what a large-scale operation
looks like and then the distribution and
marketing got Miguel Gomez in econ
Department here he studies how
distribution chains work and how you
optimize those and where the cop starts
find little things end up being big
expenses and finding ways to eliminate
those distribution chains and so there's
many solutions and many non solutions
he's working through those it's really
very interesting to watch that process
it's got a graduation strike how is
doing a lot of the legwork on that
travel we've got three distribution
companies involved because they're
really quite distinct to catch
incorporated is surprising the cabbage
business they have distribution on the
east coast from East Coast cabbage
growers so they have all the
infrastructure in place the cold
shipping but they don't do any property
I'm wanting to get into broccoli because
I see the outside of it haven't been
doing any yet so they're interested in
and that their product L&M companies
that are crawling North Carolina they
distributed primarily in the southeast
but the source from all over to
delivered
and they started during a few hundred
acres of property in the southeast you
need to go further in the summer you
need a lot more of this stuff and so
they are very much looking to New York
but that extra long ocean mist is
monitored western Packer involved ocean
mist is a medium-sized company they have
maybe eighty percent of the artichoke
markets if you buy artichokes in the
store are extremely good they also do
some profits not their big part of their
operation that is important part of
their operation they've been delivering
to Eastern markets a lot to bind up
contracts with particular grocery store
chains that's how they like to work one
of their grocery store chains as weapons
so if you buy broccoli at wegmans it is
very likely to come from this company so
they know all the efficiencies that the
Western growers have I know the quality
standards that they've been meeting so
they they have a lot to add they have
the customers already they're very
interested in reducing their
transportation costs they haven't gotten
into a before it because it looked
additional production see we don't
recognize anything
start fortunately we have people who do
know how that works and so we can make
that image the regional supermarkets
involved we tried to get regional
supermarket so they don't overlap with
each other so they'll play nice for a
couple of years anyway please start
trying to outdo each other national
chains that's almost impossible but so
we have wegmans in this area hannaford
brothers in england and eagles and
straddles the Appalachians we're working
on publix in florida we're trying to
distribute that way and so that they'll
be buying product that is produced as
part of this project for particular
periods and importantly trying to figure
out what are the qualities that Eastern
growers demand so what consumers demand
in the West is really really particular
i showed you some of those kind of bad
things
beton up in the West it's precisely how
long how long has uniform once they're
extremely in an they export to agent
then you get one step more particularly
Eastern consumers see the less
particular about things like span length
and diameter but may be extremely
particular about some other things that
we have discovered yet so that's what
the supermarkets are going to be doing
figure out kind of what they can get
away with it whether it's something
everything and then we have a lot of
growers involved building the network's
we're working with them to figure out
the economics of it because it is with
them also small things that make a big
difference huge investments to raise the
broccoli it's all done without contract
so going into the market not knowing the
price like you do with contracted crowd
so it's a high risk but the potential
for profit is is relatively large
but you need to do with the maximum
possible safety margin so that's the
story of where we're going with this
Rockford project will be and that
happening for the next four and a half
years and because it is intended to
involve a lot of people doing a lot of
publicity about it is part of the game
plans are you the odds of you hearing
something about it should be pretty good
you're getting suitable properly you
don't get simple properly rest doesn't
matter it so you didn't show some
patience some heads above ok how
sensitive are these new variety is to
the professions how reliable are they
and it's a lot more reading needed
before they become liable if you have
any idea of what genes that the breeders
have managed to select or to make them
nice when previously you shown every
other a new test it didn't appear to
associated anything prep did well the
last time start with easy done
colleagues and in fact that you've got
the sequence like they can't properly
yet the candidate a matter how to all
zeros essence Wow yeah this your she
baked ok recessive hopefully you can
gather them sequencing but if you're
consistently recessive where this ended
it can't prove it whether it's the lab I
sometime I'm not what that says I have
you don't include that that's not the
has been explained their homes are
always the like but the in terms of the
stability yes it's very good in the
reading month it's very good a lot of
the varieties tested in charlatans in
the summer don't even in the first place
they try but that's just what you want
but no ending that's that's the high
quality suppose
tolerant commercial varieties there are
some early ones that will get but look
awful these make consistently high
quality you also indicated children what
about crying them in the Adirondacks
there are all some balance in that right
collapse at night right no drawing
drawing the conventional varieties at
high elevation health what about these
new I elections high elevation and large
fertile fields doesn't usually go
together that's the drawback of that
direction to produce the quantities that
but if you asked about how much more
breeding so these are breeding lines
that have been selected for booking my
property but for having this one trait
in particular and for commercial
varieties you need to put together a lot
of different stuff that needs to have a
whole package of disease resistance you
have to have different maturities you
have to have different sizes should the
head be high or low the dome gesture
this is gallery this Robbie is the
heading multi teaming see you comment on
it if you can't do genetic engineering
of just shoving one gene
now when you shouldn't Garrod's hold
them very nicely i'm sure they're easy
to transform but they're very difficult
to salvage this one thing what would
happen to these new lines as you
subjected to colder right one back too
early well they are likely to want to go
reproductive sooner colder temperatures
and one thing we don't know that would
be part of characterizing is let's say
the set points on the regular ones is 20
degrees Celsius so it's kind of chilly
counters between 20 below 20 Celsius so
the ones that tolerate more heat is that
because the set point is dumb been moved
to 25 or that the number of chilling
hours under 20 has been reduced there's
two ways you can reach that we don't
know which of those was very descriptive
boys they've been changed in order to
get them continue to develop so if it's
the number of killing hours manager
this each would be produced in the
normal way there so they're hybrids it's
the secret process to get them to flower
at the right time across with high
fertility but also because there are
seed more diseases black rot in
particular which we have here that
really precludes produces quite thought
and also where there are specialists
is broccoli and I not value crop that
you could justify using high tunnels for
season extension probably not but the
transportation costs would be on the
border of thirty cents twenty thirty
cents a pound or so and less than that
if you're coming from Virginia so we
could extended so that we have the
season equipment Virginia and it's it's
unlikely that the high tunnel would make
that hey you're also looking at
production I'm fairly large acreages so
on the southeast the people jumped into
it and doing sort of 100 acres at a time
that's a lot
yeah it was the biggest yeah yeah for
happens so with a drop like God yep
Barry's where you're done costs it is
harvest Natural there so you said that
you have a time frame four and a half
years yeah do you think that's feasible
if you are doing these reading because
you know you'll have to make girls as
backup for you have to like get rid of
old it on the sidewalk of jeans that you
introduced with you the trousers yeah so
I mean I don't know how long it takes to
the riddle with teleport yeah but it
seems like a little bit short time
because you know that's that's one thing
yeah so there's a number of things that
one you can move fairly fast the
generation time and broccoli does let
you do several generations and all of
the starting materials is pretty good so
there's not a lot of stuff it's more
combining some traits and the other
thing we've done by bringing the three
seed companies together each seed
company wants to be the first to market
so we're counting on their competitive
spirits
because that's where the readings are
cleaning it up to
to me
I don't understand why there's such an
emphasis North Carolina Virginia South
Carolina when you say the problem is
heat the further south you go the hotter
it gets yeah I am I can understand how
diverse nation so wilds you going along
thus Lawrence Valley or something like
that where words when it's going to be
cooler rather these scream Lee hot
temperatures well there to get inside
they cool off later in the year were
twofold to grow stuff they have good so
they usually see the pictures you showed
so early spring or late fall and not if
you don't grow broccoli down the head
and summer bright South Carolina's
harvesting through November then it just
called in Florida and they're starting
transplants this week so they're
harvesting April is safe maybe less
but so to get each region have maybe
eight or ten weeks of harvest she
believed us dig a hole in the middle
a day they do have
yes hybrids less susceptible to this
opening ah I don't that doesn't seem to
be a real consistent difference we look
at open pollinated inbreds and hybrids
and the hybrids are much more uniform
but double uniformly dad also and
they're much more vigorous there twice
twice the size and what what is driving
the consumption I think it's because
it's identified with health that I think
plays a good role but also it's very
easy to use anti cancer right it gets a
lot of anti-cancer press blood pressure
plate beta I'm not quite cheap trash of
not be good thanks they're serving the
Eli fruits vegetables it'll be okay no
wrestling the president likes right
impression yes the first lady
because the production system is a once
over ideally as close as possible to
have again very synchronized these
harvest arms where the crews go through
yeah once maybe twice and that's it is
odd well two or three is about the best
and 33 is pretty normal at this points
because the hedge will only be at the
right stage for a day or two where you
are so you're going through there with
pretty quick intervals and then the
fields done Tom only hands together
plump can you come along and then get
another one produced on the side Ron
joys that you can in your garden but
commercially that doesn't fail the
United grow it fast harvesting Jimmy
avoid problems and then have the yields
are quite high
how about geneva-based questions Jimmy
that they all know about broccoli a baby
yeah close oh yeah oh I suppose the next
real challenge would be organic broccoli
right and so is that is that the next
rent and you take four more years to
control all the boats of the Vijaya and
get a nice organic broccoli that would
be very very marketable both got once he
company Pedro has a fairly large
dedicated organic division and so it's
likely that they would be producing seed
organic growers Jim Meyers has been
developing a population organic
production in the east terms of source
of broccoli regret that and for the
production recommendations we already
have production recommendations for
organic broccoli production now so that
seems like a fairly small problem we'll
be doing trials on an organic research
farm in North Carolina and with a group
of organic growers in North Carolina so
at least to that extent the organic fred
is in there right now so have the honey
good how do you control the bulbs and
the other fungi is a resistance or
something else the others there is a see
I think there's more materials for flea
beetles for instance that's when I
happen to know it from grants so so
there there are ways row covers work
real well on do Jason things up at the
selection of really quite effective
selected insecticides organic production
is pretty good
alright this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu